hey guys welcome to a brand new video
today I'm going to be going over my top
5 wilderness money making method so
these will all be very high-risk
high-reward tag methods some of them
getting up to 2 or 3 mil an hour but of
course you'll be risking quite a bit at
that point most of these are going to be
centered around combat so you will need
a relatively high combat level so either
a high range or high mutely combat
skills alright guys hope you enjoy and
let's get started so coming in at number
5 is a pretty well known one but that's
why I put number 5 and that is killing
Green Dragons now listen get you up to
about 400 to 500 hour depending on how
efficient you're doing it which is
decent and it's really not that risky
you're only in like level 15 to 17
wilderness and you can tell we're out
and people became there I usually are
not too good so you just run away either
way we're gonna want to bring is some
cheap ranging or melee gear I'm going to
be ranging them just because I have a
higher range level you're just gonna
want to bring a glory plus black D hide
as well as a room crossbow and most
importantly an anti dragon fire shield
of course if you have 55 Slayer broad
bolts are very nice because they're very
cost effective and you're not risking
anything really to use them it's always
important before we go in the wilderness
to check your items left on death so I'm
gonna be risking the boat 60km if you
wanted you don't really have to bring
the archers helm it's not really
necessary but you don't die too much
here so I'm gonna bring it I also like
to bring a burning amulet because
there's a teleport relatively close by
they can go to which is just the
abandoned camp and that's level 17
wilderness then I think you have to run
a little bit to the west from there so
from here these dragons are just down
here so it's a pretty close teleport and
if you get into trouble all you have to
do is I tell pro it was a glory or ring
it wealth but you might as well bring
the glory because you're gonna get the
stat boots from that also a range in
potions important I just give those
extra level so obviously the higher
range level is the more money priority
ones get or the higher your combat stats
but you can see how quickly these things
- I like that really don't even have
that much else at all I probably bought
a little bit too much food honestly all
they pick up is a green jacket I had in
the dragon bones and that's pretty much
it ideally you'd find a world with
nobody in it but it's pretty popular so
that may not happen now you could bring
an anti fire potion or an extended anti
fire poker but I have a decently high
defense level relatively to these
dragons at least so I'm not gonna take
how much damage it's not that big a deal
and also it's very important to
eluding beg which I forgot so don't do
as I do do as I say or whatever that
expression is this is just a nice
entry-level method in the wilderness so
if you want to try killing things here
this is a nice way to do it and a let's
move on to number four now coming in
number four is going to be actually the
revenant caves now the reason I'm
putting this solo is because there are
so many people there I had trying to
kill you so really once this has been a
bit longer it's gonna be I think even
more viable but the money per hour here
can vary quite a bit
I'd say minimum if you don't get killed
you're gonna get mill an hour so what
you want to bring is the most
cost-effective gear possible you're
gonna want a blowpipe and some black tea
I'd and AM dove glory for the slim
chance you'll be able to help or other
there now some people bring the bracelet
of etherium which makes you invulnerable
to the revenant but the likelihood of
you dying is so high right now that I
would recommend not doing it because you
lose it on death no matter what every
single time which is like a 70k loss
pretty much if you charge at all so I'm
really just bringing up full inventory
of sharks to try to get away ranging
potion and the stamina potion to get
there as well as the burning amulet to
teleport what you're gonna want to go to
the LAV amazed ideally come here with
someone with high range and a low combat
level because you will have a much
higher chance of surviving my main isn't
the ideal level because anyone can
attack me so since I'm not bringing a
bracelet of aetherium you're gonna want
to focus on the weaker and lower level
revenants because they're not too
damaging and I've really your wanted to
help her out as soon as you get anything
relatively good because someone will
come and try to kill you right away
there's a clans teleporting around all
the time just trying to kill people who
look like me guys like the revenant imps
are gonna be one shots easy to kill and
they can even drop actually on these
bolt tips or stuff like that and they're
gonna want to pick up all the revenant
Uther that's actually you somewhat
valuable and honestly once you actually
get into the cave or a little bit safer
running there can be empty actually the
highest chance of you dying not
currently anyway and it's really fun
because even low local monsters like
this are gonna get you relatively good
drops and it's just really fun actually
surprisingly I really don't like being
in the wilderness and dying a lot but
I'm actually enjoying this quite a bit
alright this is Texas drop quickly and
we got rev an ether times six which is
like a cake coming in number
is going to be killing lavage arrogance
now the potential profit here is less
but the potential for you to die is also
quite a bit less you may have noticed
that I didn't even take a looting bag to
revenant caves just because of how often
you can die however I would recommend
bringing it to black dragons
laughter aliens are most often killed
with magic
I tried no the swamp is ideal and I'm
also bringing a rims top and bottom as
well as finishing up with the rest of my
gear with kind of trash stuff and I'm
also bringing room gloves just because
they are not too valuable as far as
inventory I'm just bringing some
monkfish a bleeding bag games necklace
and some energy and stamina potions as
well as some rooms to cast how can I
grab because I'm going to be killing it
from the South room entrance
I have the reason I like doing that is
because you have a much lower chance of
dying the problem here is that there is
fatty on or something in the way which
can get quite annoying but honestly way
less annoying and get attacked by pee
cares all the time so your start off by
teleporting to the corporal beast and
then we're gonna run north to the south
or an entrance of the lava dragon Isle
so once you're out you're just going to
want to run north and if we open up the
map it's actually relatively close if
you have the agility shortcut great that
I do not have the agility level for that
currently and however it will be
extremely useful for escaping any
potential peek errors so the profit per
hour of labradorite gains can vary a bit
but you're gonna get minimum 600k an
hour assuming you don't die too much and
you can get lucky and get upwards of
maybe a mil an hour on some of your
better runs so around where the agility
shortcut is is a pretty easy place where
it can a grow the Dragons from you have
to keep in mind that you will need of
course to telekinetic grab the loot
after but for the most part if you can
attack it you will be able to grab the
loop so you can see how quickly the
Trident actually rips through the lava
dragons is really nice and these guys
have a chance of dropping in the edge of
conic village they drop onyx bolt tips a
lot and catch a dwarf as well as some
other decent consumable drops and a once
you get the drop all you have to do is
cast oh look at that first drop onyx
bolt tips 100k and we'll go ahead and
pick up the rest of this stuff too
another quick tip is actually if you
bring a pestle mortar you can actually
turn the lava scales into ground lava
scale or something
which will allow you to have a little
bit more inventory space and yeah that's
it guys a really fun method just because
the drops are so good there was a chance
to get in peak aid but it is much less
down here most people are running in
from in the side the dragon Isle coming
in number two is recharging Dragonstone
jewellery at the fountain of room now
this one is an extremely high-risk
high-reward method the main reason that
is because you're carrying a ton of
amulets of glory I well you can recharge
rings of wealth or another good wasn't
working due skilled necklaces and stuff
like that mainly those first two or the
general ones people do you can see I'm
risking 500k to go do this but the
marginal each one let's see here
we've bought them for 19.8 ke and we're
gonna sell them hopefully for about
twenty 1.2 so that's a one point 4 K
margin on each piece and we can do like
26 per inventory so it's about 36 K /
inventory charge so let's go see how
long it takes me to do this run so
things you will need is either ninety
magic and access to Diana Carl teleport
or you just need to finish ancient
magics and use an antic RL teleport
since I don't have dining magic I'm just
gonna use it to help or it's not that
big a deal it'll be a little bit less
money per hour however so to start we're
going to right-click and break the antic
Carl teleport I really appreciate that
it's not just a left click and I've
committed ability because that is
extremely risky it's gonna teleport us
to the greater demon section of the
wilderness very deep in the world II
from here we're just gonna run to the
west and there's a little spit here that
will actually go into where the fountain
of rune is and in the center there is
the fountain that you can use your
uncharged glories on to recharge them
now this is really the risky part here
because you're really stuck in here you
do all at once and you get a bunch of
glories now there also is a very rare
chance to get an eternal glory which I
don't allow much the worth now but it's
tens and tens of milk after you recharge
them you're gonna run up north to where
the obelisk is and you're going to look
for any area that's in less than level
30 wilderness and you're going to help
her out with one of your glories okay so
we got level 27 wilderness so you're
just gonna rub it ambi teleport to
edgeville and there we go run complete
it took about a minute and a half so
every minute we're gonna get about 24 K
and in an hour were getting about 1.5
mil if he runs in about two minutes
you're gonna get closer to 1 mil really
good method but an extremely high-risk
method at bat and coming in at number
one is exchanging ancient pieces for
cash in the new revenant caves now I did
this on day one and got a ton of money
but I'm gonna go test though quickly
just on that well suppose a week later
now so if we're getting a button 8k
margin on the ancient emblem right now
and that's probably the one I'm going to
end up doing just because comparative to
with the other two ancient pieces
they're margins are like 15k in 20k but
they are two in four times more
expensive so it's a really simple
principle there is at the implement
Raider in the varmint caves that will
exchange emblems for 500k one mill in
two mill respectively the ancient emblem
is 5 RK the ancient totem is 1 mill in
the ancient statuette is 2 mill really
just want to bring some defensive gear
that doesn't weigh you down too much I'm
bringing the prayer potion because I'm
going to be protecting an item and on
the very off chance someone tries to
smite me or something that I'll have a
prayer potion it's not you've lost
otherwise so we have a look at our items
lost on debt risking about 36 K which is
not too bad
one last thing you want to make sure you
bring is a dragon stone a piece of
jewelry either at glory or a ring a
wealth doesn't really matter too much so
we start by teleporting to actually the
abandoned camp and now the reason is we
need to find the emblem trader but we
need them to be ideally in lesson level
30 wilderness because you want to be
able to top her out right away
this method is much safer if he's in
level 30 wilderness were less as opposed
to having to run through the wilderness
with like a 2 mil cash for a little bit
which is not great at all so once you're
in a cave you just have to run around
and find them it's a bit of a pain but
once you've located them it's not nearly
as bad because you can power through
this really quickly and run back
extremely quick and he doesn't have much
time to move around location so much but
finding him the first time can be a bit
of a pain so the clips here are pretty
much from day one after the revenue
caves were released and I was getting
really 6 to 7 mil per hour here now that
is died down a bit and it wouldn't check
the margins if you're actually on it and
doing about 50 to 60 run
which you can totally do if you know
where the actual emblem trader is you
could still get close to 2 million our
and if you take the time and that's
using the cheapest emblem what you're be
getting an 8k margin on day when I was
getting a 40 came hargeon on it and if
he went and bought the ancient statuette
or something like that you could get
larger margins however the main drawback
is of course the price of the ancient
items it would cost you in the range of
a hundred mil plus to have enough to do
this for an hour with any of the more
expensive items anyway guys I hope you
enjoyed the video if you did don't
forget to toss it a like always
appreciated and I'll see you in the next
video